you hear it all the time but sometimes  the reason you hear [ __ ] all the time is  cuz it's really true and the fact that  matter is just way too many people sweat  the little things these micro issues  [ __ ] you you turn them into much  bigger issues than they actually are in  the scheme of things and and really one  of the things I spend most of my time  with with the people that I mentor in  management and even my friends and  family is to level up their thinking  take it and put it into perspective  don't let those little things drag you  down because if you do if you allow the  everyday little things to make an impact  you have no shot of winning the big game  non-0  you